one thing
and this particular may be preference
and quirk of mine
but i really admire maybe i'm
romanticizing the past again
but i romanticized the presidents that
were students of history yeah
there were almost like king philosophers
you know great gr you know that made
speeches
that um you know reverberated through
decades after
right then we we kind of using the words
of those presidents whether written by
them or not
we tell the story of america and
i don't know even obama has been an
exceptionally good as far as i know
i apologize if i'm incorrect on this but
from everything i've seen he was a very
deep scholar of history
and i really admire that is that
through the through the history of the
office of the presidency
is that just your own preference or is
that supposed to come with a job
are you supposed to be a student of
history i think i mean i'm obviously
biased as a historian but i do think it
comes with a job
every president i've studied
had a serious interest in history now
how they
pursued that interest would vary uh
obama was
more bookish more academic so was george
w bush in strange ways
george h.w bush was less so but george
h.w bush loved to talk to people so he
would talk to historians right
ronald reagan uh loved movies and movies
were
uh an insight into history for him he
likes to watch movies about another time
it wasn't always the best of history but
he was interested
in what is a fundamental historical
question how has
how has our society developed how has it
grown and changed over time
and how has that change affected who we
are today that's the historical question
it's really interesting to me i do a lot
of work with business leaders and others
too
uh you reach a certain point in any
career and you become a historian
because you realize that the formulas
and the technical knowledge that you've
gained got you
to where you are but now your decisions
are about human nature
your decisions are about social change
and they can't be answered technically
they can only be answered by studying
human beings
and what is history it's studying the
laboratory of human behavior
to sort of play devil's advocate i kind
of
especially in the engineering scientific
domains
i often see history holding us back
sort of the way things were done in the
past are not necessarily going to hold
the key to
what will progress us into the future
of course with history in studying human
nature it does seem like humans are just
the same
it's just like the same problems over
and over so
in that sense it feels like history has
all the lessons
whether we're talking about wars whether
we're talking about corruption
whether we're talking about economics
i think there's a difference between um
history and antiquarianism
so antiquarianism which some people call
history
is the desire to go back to the past or
stay stuck in the past so antiquarianism
is the desire to have the desk that
abraham lincoln sat at wouldn't it be
cool to sit at his desk
i'd love to have that desk if i had a
few extra million dollars i'd acquire it
right
so in a way uh that's antiquarianism
that's trying to capture and hold on
hold on to the past the past is a
talisman for antiquarians
um what history is is the study of
change over time that's the real
definition of historical
study and historical thinking and so
what we're studying is
change and so a historian should never
say
um we have to do things the way we've
done them in the past the historians
should say we can't
do them the way we did them in the past
we can't step in the same river twice
every podcast of yours is different from
the last one
right you plan it out and then it goes
in its own direction right
yeah um and um what are we studying then
in history we're studying
the patterns of change and we're
recognizing we're part of a pattern
so what i would say to the historian
who's trying to hold the engineer back
i'd say no
don't tell that engineer not to do this
tell them to understand how this fits
into the relationship with other
engineering products and other
activities from the past that still
affect us today for example
any product you produce is going to be
used by human beings who have prejudices
it's going to go into an unequal society
don't assume it's going to go into an
equal society don't assume that when you
create a social media site
that people are going to use it fairly
and put only truthful things on it
we shouldn't be surprised that's where
human nature comes in
but it's not trying to hold on to the
past it's trying to use the knowledge in
the past to better inform the changes
today
you